you do a thing where we have on it's
called unhelpful advice and people email
us question then we just try to help
them through okay or it's either horn or
odd or on on oh yeah
on hopeless bus with Craig Ferguson hi
tiger belly fan my name is Erin I'm 23
and I've been with my girlfriend for
about three years whenever I go near her
phone she freaks out and grabs it with a
physical strength i straight-up didn't
know she had I feel terrible about it
but when I went through one night and
found out she had been texting her ex
for months and it hurts because she has
told me before that she doesn't talk to
him now she has him under a girl's name
and his alerts hidden I feel like she
has a different energy in the text than
you would have with a regular friend
he's always telling her to go over and
she seems to consider it he knows she
has a boyfriend but when they talk she
will stop replying and say she fell
asleep but really she was with me I'm
starting nursing program soon so my time
will be devoted just to school and I'll
be going to bed early giving her time to
do what I don't even want to be with
this guy you've got enough information
leave wow-whee dingle-dangle in these
things but that's the truth someone who
treats you bad should I confront her the
greatest thing I ever did to break up
with somebody was make him believe that
he had done nothing wrong cook him a
meal did the laundry clean the house and
just got the [ __ ] out of there good for
you yeah I've never written now no
retaliation no confrontation just I got
the [ __ ] out yeah you have another email
online okay thank you Gilbert for a
couple months now I've been dealing with
a real toxic friendship I've been
friends with this guy for more than two
years it's my father and whenever I hang
out with him or our two other friends I
always end up paying for everything food
concert movie tickets everything I still
don't get any respect
it makes fun of my mom's business of
taking care of old people my literate
dad and my dead dog just to name a few
things I feel like
I got a live dog hey Bart mister scraps
fork rough yeah you don't do that no
quit hitting yourself
there's the answer
yeah how do I get out of it leave
[Music]